yeah welcome to this video playing holy
[ __ ] from Austria and yeah we had that
before he likes to play play him the
benoni of course this is a good opening
for white but yes let's just test if he
also knows a bit about the moral gambit
he declines it how boring
it's not a bad line to decline it of
course but it's not the most
entertaining way to play yeah we get a
position quite quite similar to the to
the more oxy point it's Amarok C bind
but without f3 and quite often black
exchanges one pair of Knights and the
bureaucracy which didn't happen here and
this is in fact something that it's
usually in White's favor the more pieces
on the board the better okay rocky one I
intend to play 95 and after taking I
want to take with the pawn so like that
okay I don't really know what his ideas
may be maybe he wants to play 97 yeah
not bad okay it's 95 mmm now at the
moment the beep to pond was hanging so
better better protected
okay yeah I don't want to exchange but
you know what what what what else I can
I can maybe play Knight g5 let you fight
but he can play 93 and 95 again
okay I didn't expect that at all how can
I takes that maybe must be should be
Section B 697 okay okay so f5 is this
good or not very very interesting
decision okay I'd like to make some
progress yeah so I go ahead
but it's debatable of course because I'm
giving up the c5 square the ideas that
have some play on the kingside like rook
f1 back to everyone trying to get
something going against they have
seventh on play on the F oh yeah I was
just I want to just want to suggest this
Bishop here and Knight f6 could be a
good idea I try to get the Queen and
here the King shouldn't be too bad then
maybe look I've won yeah I'm not sure at
all about my plan yet it's maybe not not
good oh now this is very direct
okay I don't mind if he takes to
recapture wait wait wait wait I was I
was thinking about Luke Jakes
but now that I look at it maybe maybe
there is this rook takes instead of
Bishop takes I wanted to play Bishop
takes but maybe there's Luke takes rook
takes and then going over if it takes
there have a take on g6 is very
dangerous this looks very dangerous I
don't think he can take it this is based
on intuition only maybe he can but I
don't I don't think okay so now let's
open up the position so how to how to do
that here it's
Queen age 6
maybe just cooler sticks okay you should
be success the idea of course this is
dangerous
yeah there is difficult to defend her
black if he moves the Queen for example
to to a5 or something I can't just take
g6 maybe okay not sure what the Queen is
doing doing them
okay one idea is just to go see five he
cannot take it this is too risky and if
he takes here I can take on g6 takes
Queen takes King g8 Queen h6 check it is
working okay let's do that if he takes
that take on g6 and probably the line
that I was trying to just give would
come up will be plate I this this Bishop
is unprotected so takes Queen takes King
here Queen h6 Knight h7 rook F seven
wins and he needs our King G and then
Queenie v g5 check picking up the bishop
and then I'm continuing the attack after
winning back the the piece yeah okay he
needs to take the bishop
Luke f6 is a pretty serious threat I
don't really see anything else
mm okay so just quickly so something
else I don't think so but here King to
age eight a rook check here would be
fantastic of course it would be just
winning but I don't I don't say it that
that it's possible this was my original
idea
now I get get the bishop okay justjust
take it no next rook F 4 H 4
yeah this looks very strong
Queen age six and Queen to g6 again
check
check
don't have enough time to calculate it
to the end check but I hope it's
sufficient check yeah it is sufficient
she takes Queen edge six mate and Queen
f6 Ruby f6 black for things on time it
was a dare it was a very dangerous
attack I think it was very hard to
defend starting here it's it's very
tricky for black maybe a common pair
manages to defend yeah the computer
wants to play Queen a5 had the suspicion
because Queen a5 has got this idea of
this checking idea so at first you think
that check this might win and then look
somewhere or rook f6 evening but there's
this black and this saves the day
check and now yeah white only has the
potential check yeah maybe Queen a5 was
the way after this c5 is strong yeah
this is winning actually I could move c5
and after this we get exactly the the
game check check
I look at 5 is even stronger Queen age
six mMmmm
yeah I didn't see that one and this
would have been great many peasants have
seen that rook air-five
yeah the rook air-five I was only
thinking or whatever threatening but I'm
threatening this check I only saw this
idea move later okay but my plan was to
recapture here okay this is also plus 7
according to the computer so this is
this is ok
and here we have six and I didn't see
that one but this wins this about
hopefully yeah it does okay it's a
pretty interesting game I hope you liked
it good to take I think thanks for
watching